so if you thought of any ideas for the
party yeah perfect I'm gonna do it
somewhat healthy like she was gonna have
this eye candy Liam Courtney it's not
gonna be healthy but nobody wants
Courtney Candyland is coming between Kim
and Kourtney Kardashian on Sunday's
episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians sugar is not healthy but I'm
saying let's do not the nasty stuff with
food coloring and all a clothes give me
an example of candy you want I don't
know I'll have to look into it I said we
said pattern or Danny hi and yeah this
all goes down as the sisters plan their
joint Candyland
themed birthday party for their
daughters north and Penelope which if
you'll remember took place back in June
[Music]
and as you can see the party did turn
out super cute but behind the scenes
things clearly we're not so pretty
and the theme almost changed last minute
so switch the theme a might in your area
anyone your brand this is about a kid's
party this is not about your brand yeah
but I'm saying what I stand for not even
what a good party you know I didn't
require other seats why are you wearing
plastic glasses what up to buckle like I
want a fun kids party with real candy
well that's your problem and of course
we see both sides of the argument play
out I can't believe that Kim isn't
willing to compromise at all and that
she doesn't feel guilty about giving not
only her kids and my kids but all these
kids that are coming to our party so
much junk and candy it's just like it's
such a dated five to be like that it's
just better solutions to things instead
of your dated Andy that's like literally
food coloring that gives people diseases
but for Kim it's like a completely
sugar-free gluten-free party free fun
free zone because Kourtney has decided
that it just doesn't make sense and it
really wasn't the theme of what north
and Penelope wanted for their birthday
okay to be fair they both make good
points but Kim ended up getting her way
also the sisters might have bigger
things to worry about like Courtney may
be possibly taking a step back from the
show you mentioned that you might be
ready to say goodbye to Keeping Up with
the Kardashians
where are you out on that I'm just
decided to spend more time as a mom and
you know put more of my energy there and
still but I'm not saying goodbye right
but I think you'll have to see more of
it on the new season season 18 just
crazy isn't airing yet but it's being
filmed okay and currently do you want do
you think the show can continue going if
you lose a sister yeah I mean we
definitely love Courtney and we will
miss Courtney and whatever she decides
to do but people come people go
this family we are feel like it's a
revolving door and so Kourt you might
leave this week she'll be back they all
come back alright guys that is it for
today if you want to keep keeping up
with the kardashians make sure that you
keep it locked to all things ET until
next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye for
now
[Music]